this is the key question
what do you think will happen if we
figure out the fundamental theory of
physics
right outside of the intellectual
curiosity of this this is my best guess
okay so if you look at the history of
science
i think a very interesting analogy is
copernicus
okay so what did copernicus do there had
been this ptolemaic system for working
out the motion of planets
it did pretty well but used epicycles et
cetera et cetera et cetera it had all
this computational
ways of working out where planets will
be when we work out where planets are
today we're basically using epicycles
but copernicus had this different way of
formulating things in which
he said you know and the earth is going
around the sun
and that had a consequence the
consequence was you can use this
mathematical theory
to conclude something which is
absolutely not what we can tell from
common sense
right so it's like trust the mathematics
trust the science
okay now fast forward 400 years
and um you know and now we're in this
pandemic and it's kind of like
everybody thinks the science will figure
out everything
it's like from the science we can just
figure out what to do we can figure out
everything
that was before copernicus nobody would
have thought
if the science says something that
doesn't agree with our everyday
experience
where we just have to you know compute
the science and then figure out what to
do
people say that's completely crazy and
so your sense is once we figure out the
framework of computation that can
basically do any
understand of the fabric of reality
we'll be able to
derive totally counter-intuitive things
no the the point
i think is the following that that right
now you know i talk about
computational irreducibility people you
know i was
was very proud that i managed to get the
term computational irreducibility into
the congressional record last year
um that's right but that's a whole
nother topic we could talk about right
different different different different
different topic but but um
in any case you know but so
computational irreducibility is one of
these
sort of concepts that i think is
important in understanding lots of
things in the world
but the question is it's only important
if you believe the world is
fundamentally computational
right and but if you if you know the
fundamental theory of physics and it's
fundamentally computational
then you've rooted the whole thing that
is you know
the world is computational and while you
can discuss
whether you know it's not the case that
people say well you have this whole
computational disability all these
features of computation
we don't care about those because after
all the world isn't computational you
might say
but if you know you know base-based
based thing
physics is computational then you know
that that stuff is you know that's kind
of the grounding for that stuff just as
in a sense copernicus was the grounding
for the idea that
you could figure out something with math
and science that
was not what you would intuitively think
from your senses
so now we've got to this point where for
example we say
you know once we have the idea that
computation is the foundational thing
that explains our whole universe then we
have to say well what does it mean for
other things like
it means there's computational
irreducibility that means science is
limited in certain ways
that means this that means that but the
fact that we have that grounding
means that you know and i think for
example for copernicus for instance
the implications of his work on the sort
of mathematics of astronomy
were cool but they involved a very small
number of people the implications of his
work for sort of the philosophy of how
you think about things
were vast and involved you know
everybody more or less
but do you think so that's actually the
way scientists and people see
the world around us so it has a huge
impact in that sense do you think it
might have an
impact more directly to
engineering derivations from physics
like propulsion systems our ability to
colonize
the world like for example okay this is
like sci-fi but if you
if you understand the computational
nature
say of uh of the different forces of
physics
you know there's there's a notion of
being able to
you know warp gravity things like this
can we make warp drive
warp drive yeah so like would we be able
to will it
will uh you know will like elon musk
start paying attention like
it's awfully costly to launch these
rockets do you think we'll be able to
yeah create warp drive
and right you know i i set myself some
homework i agreed to give a talk at some
nasa workshop in a few weeks about
faster than light travel so i i haven't
figured it out yet but but
no but you got two weeks yeah right but
do you think that kind of
understanding of fundamental theory of
physics can lead to those engineering
breakthroughs okay i think it's far away
but i'm not certain i mean
you know this is the thing that that um
i set myself an exercise when gravity
waves
gravitational waves were discovered
right i set myself the exercise of
what would black hole technology look
like in other words
right now you know black holes are far
away that you know how on earth can we
do things with them but just imagine
that we could get
you know pet black holes right in our
backyard you know what kind of
technology could we build with them
i got a certain distance not that far
but i think in in um
you know so there are ideas you know i
have this one of the weirder ideas is
things i'm calling space tunnels
which are higher dimensional pieces of
of space-time
where basically you can you know in our
three-dimensional space there might be a
five-dimensional
you know uh region which actually will
appear as a white hole
while under a black hole at the other
end you know who knows whether they
exist
and then the questions another one okay
this is another crazy one
it's the thing that i'm calling a vacuum
cleaner okay
so so so i i mentioned that you know
there's
all this activity in the universe which
is maintaining the structure of space
yes and that leads to a certain uh
energy density effectively in space and
so the question in fact dark energy is a
story
of essentially negative mass produced by
uh the absence of energy you thought
would be there so to speak
and we don't know exactly how it works
in our either our model or the physical
universe
but this notion of a vacuum cleaner is a
thing where
you know you have all these things that
are maintaining the structure of space
but what if
you could clean out some of that stuff
that's maintaining the structure of
space interesting
and make a simpler vacuum somewhere yeah
you know what would that do a totally
different kind of vacuum
right yes that would lead to negative
energy density which would need to
so gravity is is usually a purely
attractive force
but negative mass would lead to
repulsive gravity um and uh lead to all
kinds of weird things
now can it be done in our universe um
you know
my immediate thought is no but but you
know
the fact is that okay so once you
understand the fact
because you're saying like at this level
abstraction can we reach to the lower
levels
and mess with it uh yes once you
understand the levels i think
i i know and i'm i'm you know i have to
say that
that this reminds me of people telling
one years ago that you know you'll never
transmit data over a copper wire at more
than
a thousand you know a thousand board or
something
right and and this is why did that not
happen you know
why did why do we have this much much
faster data transmission because we've
understood many more of the details of
what's actually going on
yeah and and it's the same exact story
here and it's the same
you know i think that this as i say i
think one of the features
of sort of one of the things about our
time
that will seem incredibly naive in the
future is the belief that
you know things like heat is just random
motion of molecules
that that that it's just just throw up
your hands it's just random
we can't say anything about it that will
seem naive
yeah the at the heat depth of the
universe those particles would be
laughing at us humans
thinking yes right that life is not
civilization
you know humans used to think they're
special with their
little brains well right but also but
and they used to think that this would
just be random and uninteresting
but that's but so so this question about
whether you can
you know mess with the underlying
structure and how you find a way to mess
with the underlying structure
that's a you know i have to say you know
my
immediate thing is boy that seems really
hard but then
and you know possibly computational
irreducibility will bite you but then
there's always some path of
computational reducibility
and that path of computational
reducibility is the engineering
invention
exactly that has to be made those little
pockets can have huge
engineering impact right and i think
that that's right and i mean
we live in you know we make use of so
many of those pockets
and the fact is you know i i um
uh you know this this is yes it's it's a
i you know it's one of these things
where where
you know i'm a person who likes to
figure out ideas and so on and the sort
of tests of my
level of imagination so to speak and so
a couple of places where
there's sort of serious humility in
terms of my level of imagination
one is this thing about different
reference frames for understanding the
universe
where like imagine the physics of the
aliens what will it be like
and i'm like that's really hard i don't
know
you know and and i mean once you have
the framework in place you can at least
reason about the things you don't know
maybe can't know
or like it's too hard for for you to
know but then the
the mathematics can that's exactly it
allow you to reach beyond where you can
uh reason
right but so i'm you know i'm i'm i'm
trying to not
have you know if you think back to alan
turing for example
and you know when he invented turing
machines you know and and imagining what
computers would end up doing so to speak
yeah um you know and it's very difficult
it's difficult right and it's it's
a few reasonable predictions but most of
it he couldn't predict possibly
by the time by 1950 he was making
reasonable predictions about something
but not the 30s
right not not in the not when he first
you know conceptualized
you know and he conceptualized universal
computing for a very specific
mathematical reason that wasn't
um uh wasn't just general but but yes
it's a it's a good sort of exercise in
humility to realize that
that it's kind of like it's it's really
hard to figure these things out
the engineering of of um the universe if
we know how the universe works
how can we engineer it
you